[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qu'elles sont belles ces nanas
à la vache
elles sont belles à les [ __ ] ce alors
au [ __ ] c'est pas son téléphone sur la
photo cette paix msp cas des frais pour
venir l'aider à réaliser son blue jean
est drôlement usagers sanglots gina je
vais pas critiquer mais c'est pas une
première massa [ __ ] de dessin non là
c'est servan-schreiber
qu'est ce qu'il fout là jusqu'au bout
avec jj ss jusqu'au bout il ya quand
même pas se débloquer jss non ce serait
chouette comme argument électoral
radical j'ai tous les gus qui viennent
avait filé les dessous de la politique
par ge et ti chirac giscard d'estaing
d'en soulever mon petit accordéon mesure
une surprise
et ainsi de suite et c'est ça serai pas
triste
ça serait peut attendre jusqu'au bout et
jg c'est sûr dit quand même j'aime mieux
aller jusqu'au bout avec ma copine au
blue jeans où elle est ma copine où elle
aimerait que la revoilà aulas l'a égaré
son panty hockey
ap chaque salle
c'est chouette c'est futé ceux qui font
ça le magazine de l'homme moderne cd
futé ils sont futés qui mélange tout
jjss nadia l'aris chat
jean paul sartre zaza sème la zizanie
c'est futé un mois ça m'arrange pour
amener de la lecture à la maison un tué
parce que les filles les vraies celles
qu'on peut toucher
bon ok oui oui tous conquis quand c'est
transparent mini jupe mini short plus
banales ou shadow n'a été présentée
police comme avant l'heure qui met dans
la tête sont encore en clean ohlins
étoiles
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui reste
qu'est ce qui est vrai josette de quoi
prendre la pilule pour garder la ligne
tout est tellement d'efforts mais devant
les grossesses qu'entre deux
accouchements ou même plus la différence
il faut lutter quand on l'assoupissement
sexuelle il m'a dit le docteur jeu 8
octobre je lutte alava j'ai pas eu celle
là ça lors
[Applaudissements]